let's talk about voting I am NOT going
to bug you to vote in November not today
anyway I I've mentioned going out and
voting probably a few hundred times at
this point I'm going to be mentioning it
many many more times but not today my
question today is are you registered to
vote I'm not telling you this because I
think you're stupid
I'm not telling you this because I think
you don't want to vote I'm assuming that
our audience is going to vote in
November for these in these midterms
this is something that a lot of people
are simply unaware of because they are
busy living their lives and they might
not know that in some states there have
been movements to deregister people and
even if you don't fall under the
umbrella of the characteristic that
should get you D registered some people
are incorrectly unenrolled from voter
registration there are also lots of
states where first-time voters assume
that they can just show up on Election
Day and do same-day voter registration
but not every state has same-day voter
registration so there's a few different
things that I really think everybody
should do post this stuff to social
media tag me on Twitter and I'll retweet
this stuff and it's just so important to
be sure that there is not going to be
any reason why you aren't going to be
able to vote in November whether the
voting machines will actually accurately
capture that vote that's a story for a
different day number one usa.gov forward
slash register - two - vote okay I'm
gonna say it one more time
usa.gov slash register - two - vote or
if you're on YouTube click the Google
Doc link that we're linking to in the
youtube description for this story it
will tell you what are the specific
voter registration rules and processes
in your state if there's online voter
registration it will link you directly
to the form don't just assume that on
Election Day you're going to be able to
go out there and vote that's number one
number two the unenrolled possibility
right you want to even if you know that
you voted before you've been registered
to vote
there are systems in different states
that will unenroll you based on certain
characteristics I believe that it was in
Indiana where we covered the cross-check
system which and I don't remember for
sure and I'm going off the top of my
head if this provision was enacted or
proposed but there was at least an idea
to unenroll people who haven't voted in
two consecutive elections or something
like that doesn't even matter what the
specifics are even if you voted maybe
you didn't vote in November of 2016 you
thought Hillary was going to run away
with it whatever and now you want to
vote make sure you're still registered
still use the link in the youtube video
description or go to usa.gov forward
slash forward slash registered to vote
with hyphens between the three words the
other thing is be aware of voter ID
requirements different states have
different rules for what ID you need and
you want to have this information
present when you go to vote in November
number one because if you need ID you
want to have the right ID and show up
with it to not have any problems voting
but number two you want to know if you
don't need certain documents because
then if either you are asked for
documents you don't actually need you
can report it if others are asked for
documents that they don't really need
and maybe they don't know you can try to
intercede in that to make sure that
people aren't turned away due to
fabricated or imaginary voter ID
requirements and what we are also
linking to is a website where you can
view that information it is a link to
NCSL org they have a specific if you
google NCSL voter ID it will take you to
a page that will in very explicit terms
tell you everything that you need to
vote in certain states and it will make
it clear when you don't need other
documents to vote in those states now
let me go even further okay if you have
registered if you have voted before so
you know that you were registered and
you look it up and you are still
registered to vote that's great and then
you confirm that there have been no new
voter ID requirements
in your state and you know exactly what
it is that you need to bring there's
actually still more that you can do and
you can in many places register to be a
sort of election observer and it's a
volunteer thing but it is really really
important and it would be great if this
wasn't a partisan thing but we know that
when voter turnout is higher the more
progressive candidate tends to win
adjusting for money right so like the
candidate with more money really tends
to win most of the time but when you
adjust for money the more progressive
candidate does better when more people
vote within a Republican primary that's
also even sometimes true where if you've
got sort of more centrist Republican and
an extreme Republican when voter turnout
goes way way up the more moderate
Republican tends to win in cross party
elections Democrats and Republicans
Democrats generally do way better when
more people vote so even just showing up
and voting is political we know it helps
the left when more people vote become an
election observer so that you can be
there in November of 2018 and make sure
that people are not turned away either
with bogus ID demands or whatever else
the case may be really important stuff
and and I also want to mention if you
have any questions about a specific rule
google it this stuff is widely available
online you can even tweet me and I have
a bunch of different resources that are
abundantly clear about what the rules
are as far as ID registration and
whatever else I'm really thrilled to
tell you that today's program is made
possible in part by better help calm
slash Pakman as many of you know I have
been working very hard on this program
to reduce stigma around mental health to
reduce stigma around seeking help and I
have a family that is very involved in
mental health and if you've not already
heard about better help it is a
tremendous resource better help gives
you through your phone and computer
affordable private access to licensed
trained accredited experienced
psychologists counselors therapists and
clinical social workers
were dedicated to helping you through
whatever is going on in your life you
just go to better help calm / Pakman
fill out a questionnaire they will match
you with a counselor that will work best
for you
they are LGBT friendly you can even say
I want a counselor who's not religious
if that's important to you if your
initial match isn't a good vibe you can
switch to a different counselor and the
beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling / video phone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm / Pakman it's easy
to sign up and get started we've put a
link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube once again that is
better help calm /pa que ma n